hey guys welcome back to the FN killin
podcast the podcast that just broke its
25 streak 25 in a row streak words are
hard yes we did we did our very first
break our first break in six months
that's pretty good for six months and we
like gone on multiple trips and
vacations I mean we haven't taken a
break in the past but we're just
slackers now it's all downhill from here
I mean don't unsubscribe they're gonna
be wonderful I think it's because the
the past trips we've been on this year
have all been work trips yeah and this
one was like a family trip and we really
tried to unplug how'd we do I think we
did okay I think we got like 80% we got
we got a B gonna beat yeah we still
answered emails and I received the
comments and I posted the gaming video
but still that's like pretty good for us
it's pretty good
it deserves a B it's a B for effort yeah
okay so today we are gonna talk a little
bit about our trip which was a family
reunion well I think it's interesting
because I feel like in TV and pop
culture family reunions they're always
like family reunions but we both have
family reunions and really like them
yeah they're awesome and we lucked out
because they're in alternating years
minor odd years are even and like we
didn't have to like I don't know what we
would have done if we had have had them
during the same year we would have like
petitioned our family to change them
excuse me 50 people we need to change
for me share some family reunion stories
and then also yes return to our game
roots it's been too long too long okay
so should we start with like stories
like beets boogers or like burgers or
anything like that first I want to like
paint a picture of our family
because it's interesting because they're
so similar they're so similar when I
went to yours I was like this is the
same but it's with slightly like
slightly different people like learning
all the names of the like 40 or so
people I'm just like bad with names in
general and I'm okay with admitting it
so it's like I'm like well worst case
scenario like I'll just do what I
usually do and just like not say names
yeah so I wasn't too intimidated plus
like like we've mentioned before you
know we traveled a lot we're used to
meeting lots of new people but I did
have you like quiz me on people like on
on the flight there you made like do we
make no cards we didn't make no cars but
we made like quiz sheets for each other
did you do it for me - yeah cuz I was
stressed about it yeah I didn't want to
because you have family to me no I went
to your family unit oh yeah so I was
actually pretty stressed about not
remembering everyone's name is the very
first time so I like studied I didn't I
I I'm guessing our listeners could have
probably guessed that I feel like you
would have been more nervous because you
asked me to marry you right after the
reunion yes you're like meeting a lot of
family for the first time right before
asking and I asked your parents to like
like for their like blessing and
everything like that
yeah and I recorded like I asked him to
record videos so I could play them for
you right after we should tell the
engagement story some but yeah but for
when I went to yours we were already
engaged I guess we would have had to be
yes yes a second yeah yeah so we already
engaged so I was already like they had
to like me yeah yeah no but I mean I was
pretty confident
maybe unnecessarily so but like you know
I'm okay of meeting new people and
everything
your uncle's were a little bit not not
intimidating but they definitely like
had their like yeah just beating I
worried I worried about some of them the
ones I worried about most are actually
like okay on you yeah yeah yeah we both
come from families with lots of uncles
like lots of uncles yeah
like so there's a besides my dad there's
six other kids yeah all but one uncles
all but one I'm closer besides my dad
there's four other kids but then my
reunions are like one generation up so
it's also my dad's cousins
so more yeah so this like continued to
grow in size and scale I think that
we're up to like I think close to 50 now
yeah I think we're closer to 40 but it's
still like a lot of people it's really
hard to find houses and make everyone
happy I mean there's a lot of different
opinions like when you get to that many
people it's like a little bit of yeah
just compromising you know what I mean
yeah I mean you mean like beech versus
Mountains versus whatever yeah and
activity isn't everything like that I
mean like we usually tend to go to
beaches I mean I think that we talked
about it before when you're talking
about vacations and everything it's like
beaches are just easy to like gather
around and everyone is like in like one
of three places just the beach it's the
pool is the house you know I feel like
that is the easiest for really big
groups like but we have good mountain
hikes and other adventures and oh like a
long time ago oh oh man I wonder if I
can find footage of this but like we
went to a dude ranch where it's like you
just go to a ranch there's horses
there's like activities and everything
like that and I think that when I was
like 6 or 9 or somewhere around that age
range we went to these reunions and we
filmed an old western with like the
cousins and the uncles and the babies
and stuff and there's a plot I think
that I was like the good sheriff and we
had to like rescue people and like some
of my cousins were the bad the bad
people and stuff and shootout and
everything was it all cousins there were
the uncles and aunts like part of the
Act owes me mostly cousins but I think
at one point there are some babies in
there and like the uncles were just like
holding the babies and moving them
around and stuff like that it was like
so long ago I was on a VHS tape and like
I think it's converted somewhere in the
somewhere in the data realm somewhere it
might be on one of these servers
and I've I've seen um like some
individual clips from it because I
remember seeing one of your uncle's like
holding a baby Anna beer yeah yeah yeah
that's Athena I remember - I don't think
I've seen you and your your amazing
acting skills is that what led you to
youtube we shall see look it up later
don't spoil anything yeah so um what are
some of your favorite favorite memories
from from family reunions in general we
used to do a lot of cousin pranks hmm oh
I've heard about the toothpaste one oh
yeah that was a good one that might be
my favorite a lot of boys versus girls
cousin pranks cuz we're pretty evenly
split down the middle of the toothpaste
one did the boys got us and they had
gotten this like clear ghost pepper hot
sauce in town and they put it on our
toothbrushes you can't see it because
it's clear and you like put toothpaste
on you start brushing your teeth and you
ridge like at first taste the toothpaste
and then just like the best part about
that story is I love that they got too
many people they got your mom didn't
they toothbrushes were whoo so they got
like yeah they got my mom they got a
couple other innocent bystanders
typically limited to the cousins didn't
you do something like like the typical
like summer school prank where you put
stuff on like the fans we put cereal on
their fans yes we put jellyfish in their
toilet we probably shouldn't have done
knowing looking back it's not good for
the jellyfish or the toilet yeah what
else do we do I mean we would like paint
their nails when they sleep and once I
had face paint for some reason maybe I
probably brought it just for the pranks
yeah face painted them I think that I
have gotten attacked I have got I fell
victim to the nail-polish that's the one
that still prevails we you know we we've
we've matured and we no longer play
pranks on each other but the nail polish
if any male and the house falls asleep
at any point in any of their nails are
any nails are excessive girls toes
anything yeah those nails will be
painted and all of the girls like like
start like gathering like running off to
get the supplies and everything and
there's always like some nail polishes
around no one ever has nail polish
remover and that's like the rule like if
you get asked if you have nail polish
removers like oh no I didn't bring any I
think they got me with like glitter nail
polish oh that's the worst yeah it was
the best yeah yeah it's it's fun cuz
like you know we started that when I was
like a young teenager and now some of my
other cousins are that age and I'm like
yes about passing it pass on the
traditions yeah yeah I think that's on
my favorite memories are actually I
think that we were in Florida I believe
at the beach and I think my favorite
memory is all of the cousins went down
to the beach at night for some reason
and there are some bioluminescent
bacteria or something in the water so
that like when the waves crash it kind
of glowed like slightly but if you walk
out into the water and you wave your
hands around behind you there's a trail
of like glowing I mean they're probably
animals they're little little floaty
things but it looks like glowing
particles so it's like you felt like it
magical power so you could go like wow
like fling your hands out and like
spells would like shoot out from your
hands and it looked amazing it was the
coolest thing and we just like hung out
in the water at night for hours like
doing magic spells and like singing
Disney songs dang that yeah that's
awesome we've we've seen the
bioluminescence before but it was
different it was like less concentrated
and it was just a little bit more subtle
like you could kind of see it in the way
tiny little flickers or something you
could see it like as you walked on the
beach like your concept so kind of
disrupt I think I might have been there
you might have been there have you been
there we've seen it a few times and it's
like what there's one time I don't know
if it's always the same thing there's
one time where these tiny little clear
like jelly looking things that didn't
sting you and we collected them all in a
bucket and then we'd shake the bucket
they'd all glow oh wow that's great
like a concentrated and then we'd
release them yeah I wonder if it's like
a certain time of the year or just like
luck like if they're in your area while
you're there or something like that
there's like a passing by colony of like
glowing we found interesting so so
because of that we always go out to the
beach at night do some time just to
check and so the first night at this
most recent one we went out to the beach
and we didn't find the bioluminescence
so John's boogers that's what we called
ours anyway we call them to see buggers
yeah so it's like you know but anyways
yeah we found these little clear about
the size of a dime but like a long day
yeah like us like a slug like a slug yes
and at first I thought they were like
the sea boogers which are these clear
jellyfish that have like no discernible
parts in them they're just like a little
clear chunk but then as we started
looking we realized that they actually
had little internal organs yeah they
have internal organs they had tiny
little like like that yeah and like they
were different colors there was like an
orange kind and then one that had like a
dark blackish and some have been them
I'm at Coupole I don't think it was
actually poop because all the orange
ones had the thing that we thought was
poop well we had a little brown sack
inside of them so could be like an organ
it could be an organ I think it's poop
orange ones really had to poop like
really badly really badly I think one of
the cousins afterwards looked it looked
it up and I think that they're just like
a little like not-not-not single-cell
but like they're like a just like a
small little organism that floats around
in colonies in the sea and they actually
like help clean up the ocean and
everything so like they're cool it was
interesting cuz we didn't see any during
the day but at night this is all washed
up on shore they were suiciding yeah
yeah let's see so what else during this
reunion I think that one thing that
that's interesting about our unions is
every night like one family cooks and
it's like one family cooking for 50
people yeah yeah yeah there's like math
massive pots and like it's just like a
crazy feet I think yeah and plus it's
like so interesting like the juggling
that goes on during like breakfast and
lunch and like sometimes one family's
cooking for a lot of people and then
like sometimes it's a free-for-all and
it's just like well this one was crazy
normally we can't find a house that fits
everyone this time we found a house it
was like a twenty three bedroom house
everybody but it had one cooktop one
cooktop yes it's like that's a little
bit crazy it had two ovens two
microwaves like live refrigerators but
one cooktop yeah hey we made it work
yeah we did shuffling around I mean we
definitely like my mom led the charge
like a hundred percent you know like we
were all like sous chefs like juggling
around like cooking the bread and
setting things out labeling things so
everyone had responsibilities we were
responsible I mean we did like prep work
beforehand but when it's go time
everyone had like your responsibility so
that everything's ready we were
responsible for the bread cuz we had
three different types of bread we had
bread we had like picked up from the
store or from from a restaurant we had
some bread that was like the frozen
garlic bread and then we had some
gluten-free bread because there's some
gluten-free people in the family and so
it was like they all had to be cooked at
different temperatures and we had two
ovens but we also had lasagna in an oven
so it's all just like shuffling and so
we're like okay we got this we will do
the bread it was like a decent chunk of
it like almost half of the garlic bread
we like burnt the bottom like horribly
because we were just looking at the top
and the top cooked like well but the
bottom cooks liked it like like a
charred and a burnt and those horrible
we were it was on a pretty low rack
which is just where the rack was and I
guess we just like left it and you even
said beforehand or beforehand um I was
trying to move it yeah there wasn't a
good like oven mitt like there's just a
wet towel which will burn you and so I
was like it's fine and you really should
do it well me do it and I was like no no
you'll burn your hand no no it's not
worth it it'll be fine
it wasn't fire I mean we cut off the
burnt bottom and we got some like semi
usable bits off of it we did but like we
lost we we were like scrambling as
people cuz like once the food is out
people start eating sometimes there's a
limited amount of the good stuff so
everyone like wants to get in there you
know it's like a mad rush of 50 people I
was like we were like desperately sawing
off the burnt part of the bottom of this
bread I'm like trying to chop it and
make it look just like going at it but
but also because so we'd made pizzas the
night before and I think and there had
been some like cheese and stuff that
kind of fell that was making a little
bit of a smoky smell burning we're doing
the pizzas but it was like oh noes and
cheese just fell off yeah um and so I
had I smelled burning when we were
cooking we just saw this from last night
it was just like the dang cheese it
wasn't it was the bread scarred forever
like bread like 75% of the bread came
out just fine and the other 25 was just
you know kind of half destroyed
by the end of the Union reunion like you
know everyone's in like free shuffle but
there are a lot of vegans and there's a
lot of vegetarians in our family which
is cool it's good for the environment
and and everything like that but like
towards the end we were just like
non-meat it out we were just like
craving meat so bad so like at the end
we just like went and got like the best
burger ever I don't know if the burger
was like like legit that good or if like
good well it was like that the lack of
meat for a few days like got us yeah but
yeah it was this like little burger
place down the street and we we didn't
have a car for the trip I guess we could
have walked but it's also like
everyone's eating lunch inside you don't
want to like leave and do your own thing
but by the end when we were on our way
to the airport yeah my family's a little
bit more chaotic when it comes
I wasn't gonna say so but you can say so
you guys are so organized everyone's got
a night maybe it's because like uh you
know it's easily divisible you know you
have the 7 families 7 days 7 families 7
days yeah it works out so nicely yeah
for us there's like five families of
like the brothers related you know
directly related Michael my dad's
brothers yeah then there's lots of other
pockets that are like my dad's cousins
and their siblings yeah and there's just
no easy way to do it there's no clean
line there's no clean line yeah we've
never had a process of being organized
about it what do you you do have one
night where you really organize maybe
even two we have like two to three
nights and then the rest is just like
nobody ever does yeah cuz you always
have like Lebanese night amazing was a
night where my parents do a big thing
yeah my parents often like entertain for
big part and then leftover night there's
leftover night where everybody brings
all the Lebanese night is so good cuz
everything is hand like pretty much
handmade yeah I like people who know
what they're doing it's just so nice
[Laughter]
yeah it's it's fun reunions are crazy
and I think like when I was younger I
didn't really realize that like I think
it's a more it's a relatively rare thing
for this larger of like family group to
get together on such a regular basis
every two years yeah I think one thing
that like I thought about a decent
amount while we were on vacation and
while we were coming back is like
vacations in general with like what we
do I know that we had like kind of a
whole episode about like why we can't
take a vacation yet that was more on the
work side but also like an update on
that it's just it's I'm not sure if I
have a desire for vacations as much
anymore because you know the cost I know
the cost that's like a decent part of it
and I think that we can get better about
like bringing it down
Specht getting farther ahead and
everything but also it's like when we
got back from the vacation and we are
like we had caught back up because the
for every day like every like every time
we get back the first day back from
vacation is like ah do emails catch up
do all the posts like send payments out
like process invoices like do all like
that it's just a concentrated dose of
the business see things that aren't good
aren't like like joyous thing is you
know I mean but then the day after like
there's only one day of catch up and
then like the day after we were doing
like real stuff and I'm like I'm really
happy I'm really content with the day
I'm really content with like what I'm
doing right now and I don't know there's
I mean maybe the answer to that is we
just need to outsource some of the
business e stuff I don't know how to do
that cuz we've talked about it and
thought about it
and it's like I just don't I just don't
think it's possible I mean like like all
of these things that we deal with it's
like if we had someone else deal with it
would still may need to make the
decision or say yes or no or review it
or yeah like all that time still goes
into it yeah and we don't I think the
main thing that would be saved by hiring
out like you know like a manager or
something yeah would be like procuring
of deals but we don't spend that much we
spend more time working with existing
clients like reviewing contracts and
like proposing videos and all that we'd
still have to do that it's like we want
to shape the way we work with brands
because we want to be natural we want to
work with the people we want to work
with and yeah I don't know yeah like it
wouldn't take that much off of our
plates and then we just have a person to
manage yeah I mean we've gone down this
path so many times like what else what
else can we outsource Wells can we hand
off and it's like not much it's hard
really the main thing is editing but you
don't want to give that up and I kind of
totally see it now and I agree because I
gave it a shot you did and it's not that
it was it wasn't like a negative
experience it's just I realized that
there's it's really hard to communicate
when you want what you want and I we
realized that we were still kind of
changing our editing style yeah it's
like a moving target so it's like I have
two analogies it's like it's like yeah
it's trying to hit a moving target that
works just as is but it's almost also as
if you're trying to tell someone else to
hit a moving target so it's like it's
like if you're if you're uh like if
you're an archer and you're you're
you're shooting like add a target that's
easy if you're trying to hit a moving
target that's harder but you can kind of
see it you see the speed of the target
you can like predict where to aim and
fire in that direction you know but like
let's say that you're looking at the
target and smoothing and someone else is
firing and they can't see the target you
know I mean that's really hard to
describe like Oh more to the left more
to the right more to the left it's like
it's like it's it's really hard to do
because they like you know we are in the
channel every day we're getting that
real-time feedback we're engaging with
our viewers where we're hearing like I
know there's a lot that goes into like
feeling where the channel is at and I
feel like we know that and you know we
need to know where to aim I don't know
I'm kind of like saying the same words
over and over again I think I've made my
point so I'll stop well I think that
that's the thing yeah yeah so I don't
know I'm not really sure like what would
make it easier I know it easier I know
what would make it easier to hand things
off if we came up with a series that was
a thing that like had an intro outro
like all of that stuff that's why the
gaming channel is easy to hand off yeah
a whole thing's kind of like a series
it's the same format same time no matter
what the game is yeah it's just the
camera records everything yeah yeah yeah
it's very very consistent
good job us I mean if we let's say it on
the main channel we came up with a
series so let's say okay so the the Bob
Ross painting that was that was one of
the videos more than any other video
where people were like you should make
this a series you should make a series
that's something that I could see us
being able to out
yeah because we were like hey we did
this again use this as the template go
you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's true I mean maybe we should come
up with a series because it it it would
help it would help it you know it's not
that coming up with ideas it's hard we
have so many ideas that like I know
we're never gonna get to the ideas are
easy but because everything is a
different type of project or often
relearning how to film so like for
example the garage project the garage
makeover that we just did was totally
different because most of the work was
just like us cleaning out the garage
yeah and then like assembling some
cabinets it's not a typical project
where there's like oh we're gonna
experiment and then we're gonna do the
real thing or you know whatever yeah and
the same thing with the moving target
thing I mean like the very first time we
did a garage renovation video it was
like a lot of montage quick cuts through
the whole thing very little in the
moments talking and it's a completely
different video than the garage makeover
we just they're the same type of video
in a way but like so entirely different
results so I think that that just goes
back to the movement target I mean
that's like a very long period in
between that and we've moved a ton since
then yeah but like yeah it's like we
can't show people templates for things
because like it's just so different also
like if if our videos were we introduce
the design then we get the materials
then we saw them down to size then we
glue them then we assemble them and then
we finished them every single time then
we come up with a template you know but
that's not often how it is and also
there's always like mess ups there's
always like unique stories we tell or
what have yous and we want to lean into
that and continue making things like
feel like us because it literally is
just us figuring it out every time so
much of that comes through and edit
which is like all praise to Caitlyn yeah
yeah I mean well
I think I think the way to like continue
having vacations and enjoy them as much
as we can it's just like it seems
strange but like you know I think that
we came to the same conclusion at the
last podcast where I talked about
vacations work harder get ahead figure
things out come up with templates and
then like and then we can take a
vacation
for like two years now which is really
really hard then when you take a break
but we've gotten better you know I say
that kind of jokingly our videos take a
little bit less time we're able to do
smaller projects in general every now
and then you know it's like we've fairly
well automated the gaming channel
podcast isn't that much of a like big
thing hanging over our head or anything
so it's like you know giving ourselves
credit where credit's due you know we've
done a lot in the past six months I feel
like the six the last six months have
been like kind of crazy we started the
gaming channel like we passed a 10k on
gaming channel yeah we start the podcast
six months ago we started the podcast
expunged ago I think the last 12 videos
have been doing like like the past maybe
even 14 videos now I've done like really
really well for our size you know we're
we're finding our groove and everything
like that I think that we've done yeah
it's been a good six months and but we
are definitely in that mode of like if
we just work really hard now then we'll
be able to take a break yeah I think so
I mean and I think that honestly looking
at other people who are in our industry
it's kind of a common thread yeah you
know and we don't really like like I
feel weird talking about it sometimes
cuz I don't want to sound like I'm
complaining because it's really a great
place we're at but not just that I just
don't like the whole like I'm so busy
all the time you know I don't like that
either
but I always want to share our truth and
where we're at and that's kind of our
truth and where we're at I don't know
yeah I I don't want to glorify it I
guess yeah I don't this because like
this isn't for everyone this isn't the
most healthy especially long-term you
know I mean
back to vacation source we live the
games to game okay let's pull up I'm
gonna pull up my my game list right now
while you describe to people what the
game is
okay so there's a new game we don't have
a clever name for it but it's movies in
two words so basically you get two words
to describe a movie it cannot use any
words in the title and he character
names and it cannot be a quote like a
two word quote and that's it and the
other person was against the movie okay
battle are yours numbered because I want
to like do the same amount and then we
can like total up the score let's go
back and forth okay guys so the very
first clue this is a movie and I'm
describe it in two words just kind of
worried like some of mine I'm like oh
man this is way too easy and some of my
like I'm actually really curious because
I think that like we might cut like
there's like a couple of different
movies that all of these could be you
know I think all of them are fine I'm
just really curious like I'm gonna say
I'm gonna say something and then like
some I even have multiple videos written
down because like it can go multiple
ways okay so it's like an easy one that
gives this destroy asteroid Armageddon
or Armageddon deep impact I haven't seen
that you haven't seen that like they're
the same movie that came out like back
to back there like a bug's life and ants
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's like that's
a really easy example yeah alright so
what seems supernatural pests
supernatural pests spider-man no
supernatural pests not aliens pasts
supernatural pests it could be like so
many things what's the thing we like you
don't feed them water pass a certain
time true but but
but when you know which one Ghostbusters
yeah they're like they're like
exterminators okay but like okay but
like what what's the one we're like
gremlins those are supernatural pasts
true but like I feel like what I want to
do a supernatural pest control yeah yeah
and that would have gotten it out of
that three more yeah yeah supernatural
pass okay um repeat cycle looper that
see that that work what's another one
Groundhog Day yeah that's what I was
going for but there's another one that I
thought of like just right now as I was
saying it what's the one with like Tom
Cruise and like Emily Blunt
yeah that's so good tomorrow day after
tomorrow
no that's the that's the the
supernatural or that's the end of the
world day after tomorrow's like the slow
one this is the one with the aliens
yeah tomorrow that was a really good one
too it's a repeat cycle could be so many
things like living into two words opens
it up to like a lot of different movies
I think we had if I had five words we
could have like but then it's too easy
oh but it might be too easy okay your
turn okay boat sinks Titanic yeah I'm
sinkable ship oh yeah okay except it
sink unsinkable ship if I hadn't had
three words unsinkable sink ships
I mean I'm single ship sinks okay
[Music]
scary shark in-law disapproval in-law
disapproval what's that movie that we
started and never finished that one
let's get out it seems like that's a
little bit of in-law disapproval oh yeah
but we haven't seen the full movie
mute the Fockers meet the parents okay
okay
Meet the Fockers okay rebel scum rebel
scum Star Wars yeah I have a really good
one coming up okay okay um metal mail
metal mail like chain mail ma le Oh
Matt's whole mail Terminator no oh come
on he is a metal mail he is this one
take it more literal terminator no take
it more take those two words I Robot no
no no no Iron Man yeah okay so it if you
took those two words like literally for
the title of the movie that was my
follow-up clip I thought about doing
Iron Man I thought of like changing Iron
Man to like two different words but I
thought I was late describe me you can't
it's like like like two clue in the
title right okay okay now this is a good
good this is how you do it let me show
you let me show you Colorado staycation
Colorado staycation yeah Colorado
Colorado Colorado stay yep this a family
go to Colorado if they're going to
Colorado it's not a staycation Oh
staycations where you stay home yeah
yeah I think it still describes it okay
so they live in Colorado they're living
in Colorado during this they're
vacationing in Colorado and you didn't
want to use the word vacation mm-hmm
I don't know I like my word shining yeah
[Laughter]
I know right cuz it's like just a family
chilling like working on a novel you
know kind of a staycation it was like a
temporary because it wasn't a vacation
yeah cuz he like they're taken care
you know they're working but they were
like living there and everything I don't
know I thought it was like kind of
clever okay
[Music]
cold sister frozen oh yeah yeah I I have
a hard one colored stones
okay here's um I see em I see red pill
matrix dang it
balloon house okay okay
kids band high school musical no uh
house of rock school of rock here let's
do let's do a harder one I'm not sure if
this will work but only one only one I
mean it could be like I am Legend cuz he
was the only one alive no no nobody
there there were more there were more
that's not it
cuz he found people at the end right I
don't remember okay the dog Cena so sad
only one okay it's an older movie older
movie it has a sword in it the sword in
the stone
no I'm not sure if you've seen it well
have you seen it I've seen it long time
ago what would be a third word can only
one can word it doesn't need to be a
sentence can only be one there can only
one
everyone's getting it now I kind of went
the quote route why I feel like it was
on the tip of my time it's old there can
only be one it's an old movie
everyone knows there can only be one
it's all it's an old movie with a sword
yeah okay if you haven't gotten into
this one you're not gonna get it as
Highlander oh I've never seen only be
one okay I win even even so far we've
always done it so I'm one point ahead
I'm winning right now okay I mean it's
kind of cheating because you haven't
seen the movie so yeah
death follows death follows Oh reminds
me of a book that I read where like like
there's like a kind of evil entity that
followed him around that always tries to
kill him death follows oh oh oh the ring
no oh come on
9 days later death follows 9 days later
yeah this is much more when you know the
movie it's much more fitting I mean you
could say death follows for like most
scary movies but this is like specific
like like like this is like the whole
theme death follows like follows like
like death you can design this nation
yeah it's pretty good it's pretty good
Wolfpack Balto nope Wolfpack attack
they're actual wolves in it nope
okay just dudes is it older movie or new
a movie Zach Galifianakis democritus oh
yeah I forgot about that line yeah a
lone wolf wolf pack moan wolf wolf pack
alright my turn okay
alien communication et phone home
I mean et yeah oh come on
this is another one kind of like the
other where it's like you could make it
like apply to a lot of movies but
there's one that's like very
specifically yet alien communication
what's the what's the movie where like
it had like a really trippy scene where
like aliens were like sending in like
codes okay I know the one that you're
talking about now but there's another
one that I'm thinking of aliens were
standing in this data and they're trying
to interpret it and then someone came to
the realization that they were sending
in like 3d data and then turned out to
be blueprints and then there's
blueprints for like this huge
transportation so you're like this huge
like like device and this person hopped
in the device and she went like she
dropped through the this portal and she
saw the aliens and everything but like
from the external side of things it
looked like no time had passed but to
her she like had this whole journey
through life in that moment it had known
believed her was pretty good I think
that like some aspects have a good was
good but alien communication is the the
one with like the stone slabs that drop
down she's like seeing the words and
there's the tentacle monsters on the
other side and the gasps and like do you
know the name communication signal I
mean I'll give it to you I think no no
it's a good movie it was a really good
movie let me tell you symbols those
symbols
when you get to a place you decision no
arrival okay um let's see
trash compactor central to the movie
wall-e things up and make cubes out of
it okay
feline ruler clanking okay last one last
one all right
precious ring do you have a good one a
good one
okay let me see if I receive any of my
Erhard I think what we've learned is we
need to make these a lot harder like
kind of almost purposely misleading kind
of like the Colorado staycation yeah
okay no all of mine are pretty easy okay
gun pageant oh yeah yeah yeah I know it
I know it she's an undercover cop she's
the same actress that's and speed so
what I'm learning is like you know the
movies he was really bad at movie names
you know I'm bad at remembering
everything yeah but no but you know the
movies I know the movies on another
whole plot like she's an undercover cop
she needs to like like do the beauty
pageant she has like this like she goes
like this secret facility and she like
gets this makeover and she walks out and
then like the love interest is like whoa
and then like she like bombs and she
like you know grows as a person and
someone describes their perfect date
yeah April 30 second it's not too hot I
mean you want me to give it to you No
no good luck I want a like Legally
Blonde they know that's not at all like
a good thing I don't know why that pops
into my I tried to do Legally Blonde but
I couldn't come up with something where
the word blonde wasn't used lawfully
yellow you could have been bend snap oh
yeah bend snap then snap but see like a
clue again the quote that's a quote and
like you get it in one go yeah that are
hard enough um dang it does that mean
that we're gonna tie if I don't get this
I know I think I think you still win cuz
I had like no idea about what we want to
word title does that help I know it
sewer title for some reason I have it in
my head it's like that's why I think of
Legally Blonde but first let me give you
the first word word is something you'd
use to like address someone microphone
know like like Miss Miss Congeniality
you got it does it alright and this
concludes our game of the week now we
know we need to make it even hard time
with this though
time for the wait you said I said game
of the week okay now it's time for
things yes
so my thing of the week is an Instagram
account Nathan piles change planet
comics it's so good we'll have a link
below it's like Nathan W pile strange
planet but like oh just like it's like
like wholesome and like so relatable and
like so cute and like we first saw there
his we first saw his comments on reddit
like every day on the front page yeah
boom boom boom boom you realize he has
an Instagram account he posts comics
every single day yeah but it's like it's
like would you want to describe it it's
these aliens and they're on earth doing
earth-like things but they're explaining
them in like an alien way kind of like
like I'm five in the what's like in a
very literal way and they're they're
completely literal completely literal
and like it points out hilarious thing
is that humans do don't really make that
much sense yeah one of my favorites is
like one of the aliens gives the other a
candle yeah for Christmas and it's like
here's a primitive light source it needs
another tool to make it work oh and then
he's like it smells like sustenance but
you cannot eat it
[Laughter]
are you gonna read one was my rendition
that bad no it's good it's good that's
it I just wanted like I just want to
read one more here I'll describe one
more comic it is two aliens at the
amusement park and one is saying I do
not want to perish today another says
but to become in but to be briefly
convinced that we will and then they're
on the roller coaster and one of them
says death feels eminent this feels
genuinely unwise we are truly fragile
mortals and then it says we did not die
but the moments of uncertainty were
uncertainty were my favorite yeah did I
do a good job rate me on YouTube please
give me a five stars radius on iTunes
podcasts okay okay I think I'm gonna end
my career of reading comics for now yeah
that's good um so my thing of the week
is called spikeball oh I never heard of
this related to the reunion
it's related to the reunion we've played
it at my reunion annual reunion but
actually I think I didn't play it in
mine it's so fun it was too hot cousin
Florida and mine we're in North Carolina
for years it was little cooler but it's
so fun I'll describe it as like
volleyball but on a circular net on the
ground but also kind of like if he mixed
volleyball with like Foursquare
Foursquare yeah yeah I was like
Foursquare yeah instead of going over a
net you're trying to hit a net on the
ground that the ball bounces off of but
it's super fun it's so fun yeah it's
like a great beach game it's really
lightweight
we will put a link to the one that we
had at the beach yes but yeah that's my
new favorite oh I don't know if I can
say my new favorite beach game I still
do like bachibachibachi balls great bye
bocce ball between bocce ball and spiked
ball you're covered at peach yeah but
spike ball is a little bit more
fast-paced and everyone's like all four
players are just going all the time it's
not like the depends on like if you want
to have a beer sip your beer and throw
balls then bocce ball you want like go
go go and be active then spike ball yeah
it's fine game yeah and that concludes
our podcast yeah we did it again after
again skipping a week we don't get too
much about how to do this just a little
bit just a little bit all right guys
thanks so much for joining us today
we'll look forward to seeing you next
week and bye
[Music]